Hello, how are you, Sali Jaramillo greets you
with your brief information today,
Monday, February 1st,
tomorrow the new vaccination center opens
at the
Las Vegas Convention Center, the public is reminded
that this center will only be for
people waiting to receive their second
dose  of the vaccine the clinic will be
open from Tuesday to Saturday in zone c1
of the central or central corridor or
the public is also advised that they do not have
to call to make their second appointment
officials from the health sector will
contact you to schedule your
appointment  to receive the second dose for
now they will focus on people who
received their first dose at the
wasting facebook high school clinics
or the casement center or in
the southern nevada health district
and this morning
the 2021 legislative session began in heart center
and Nevada state legislators are expected to
address issues related to the
pandemic and the state budget and
how to eq  ubalancing it the
state budget is perhaps very important in
this session because it includes
education and medical care usually the
legislative session is open to the
public but due to security measures due to
the pandemic it will
remain closed to the public
and there is a month left for students
studying  first to third year return to
the classrooms of cis schools
and it is from parents they received a
letter from the school district informing them
that the return to face-to-face classes
would not be normal. our team of
reporters obtained a copy of the letter
which also details them  to parents that
the playgrounds will remain
closed and that both students and
teachers must have their
masks on at all times and they are also
informed that breakfast and lunch
will be served in the classrooms and
students will be limited to moving between the
buildings  campus and may only
be in their classroom or to specific restrooms
apart from
some students will continue their
educational plan without teachers physically
present the hybrid plan consists
of students continuing their studies
from home at least three days a
week while teachers conduct
face-to-face classes on campus
students will be assigned readings and
other simpler projects when they
are not present in the classrooms of course
we will be reporting as
the date approaches
the president of bailén signed several
decrees on immigration
last week it was expected that he would sign a
series of executive orders on
immigration including decisions
on separation  of families, the
asylum and refugee process, among others, but
according to the White House spokeswoman,
the administration postponed these
decisions until this week
, therefore immigration experts and activists
ask immigrants seeking to
process documents to be very
careful who they go to.  in which to help them
is the moment in which scams
increase it is important that the community
knows that there are people in the community who
want to take advantage of our of
our people it is important to say and if
the community of angol that looks very
not  I know how to say it but if the promises
are too high it doesn't work now we'll move on
with your weather forecast,
a day with many clouds and temperatures
close to normal is expected for tomorrow it will return
to the sun have a good day
I am I went out jara mine and this was new
sound in Spanish
[Music]